[Music]
you have diehard fans who are white who
are quite Korea and they're quite
creative but for some arbitrary reason
they are obsessed on the internet with
depicting you as a giraffe oh yeah I've
seen that and I don't know I mean it's
just this thing that they've become
obsessed with and it seems to be feeding
on itself now that's how those memes
work yeah but we have I think we have a
couple here there's you these are all by
fans that's fantastic let's keep moving
through these there you are appearing
through someone's window and then
there's this one right here which I
thought was quite moving that Jesus well
this is one front this is a yeah look at
that one I mean they're really they're
quite creative but I don't know I've
wanted to be the giraffe that's a noble
creature yeah yeah if it doesn't bother
anybody yeah leaves doesn't kill anybody
it just eats leaves and mines its own
business and it has a really long neck
and it looks like it's walking in slow
motion I'm honoured to be on it it could
be worse sure I'm speaking of animals I
was reading up on you today and you said
one of your favorite movies of all time
is Dumbo yeah that's that's not think
that people love the movie Dumbo what is
it about Dumbo specifically that grabs
you is there any I mean probably it's
one of the earliest movies I remember
watching with my mom yeah so that
probably does it but it's I don't know
it's just also a really good movie makes
me cry every time it does make you cry
there's there's a particular scene in
Dumbo that gets to you is there yes what
scene is that exactly where he gets
taken away from his mom and his mom's in
jail and you know she's got her trunk
out the window of her jail cell and
she's cradling the little baby it's a
moving scene yeah it gets to you yeah
let's take a look at it now
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was almost realist except we saw
you do that I was gonna say ever her so
we thought like oh maybe we could show
that I was thinking has Dumbo make you
cry cuz I haven't seen that such a long
time I started to show that scene I was
like oh my god that is hardcore that is
rough I forgot those those early Disney
films that were playing around no
they're not playing around when you see
them as a kid they're incredibly rough
yeah well fairy tales classically happen
I mean fairy tales were always told to
kids to actually teach them something I
don't know what that meant you just
revealed your true nature let's talk
about hit record auntie this is a
fascinating this has been a passion
project of yours for a long time yeah
this is not something you just attached
your name to this is something you've
been thinking about for how many years
well I mean it started in 2005 the first
version me and my brother started and it
grew organically it didn't start out as
a television show but we've been doing
it for a long time and now yeah we make
this TV show and we put the
collaborations up on our site our
website and artists from all over
contribute to these collaborations that
I direct and it's not so much that
people put up finished works and I pick
watch which ones go up on television we
do lots of different pieces all together
someone will write it that someone else
will do the voice-over someone also you
know put it on illustrations and when
you talk about someone I mean this is
really a collaboration with you and
people in the world are putting it out
there and so talented people anywhere
they don't even have to have necessarily
be be famous or well-known that's just
the thing there's so many great artists
all over the world who don't necessarily
have the opportunity or they don't live
in Hollywood they don't have an agent
but that doesn't mean they're not really
good at what they do yes you know so
those are the people that I want to be
working with to make this show